we can all perform at 90 percent but you
want people to get to a hundred and to
get to a hundred you have to be inspired
by something you have to be working for
some greater cause there has to be some
reason for doing it that's beyond the
just being excellent at something that's
about leaving the world better than we
found it and so that's our gravitational
pull that's our North Star
hello I'm Tim Cook and I'm going to talk
about the five things that inspire me
one of the main things that inspires me
are customer nodes I religiously look at
customer notes every morning starting
around 5 a.m or so if you're in the
business like we are of creating
technology that really enriches people's
lives you want to know what it's doing
you want to know how people are feeling
about it I get some of the most
heartwarming notes I got one just this
morning where a driver of a car went
into a seizure and because they had the
iPhone 14 the crash detection detected
the crash and called immediately for
help when they couldn't do it themselves
these are just phenomenal notes of
people telling about technology and what
it will do for them and and specifically
what Apple products have done for them
of course I get some complaints as well
and those are cool too because I want to
stay grounded in terms of what our users
are thinking what they're feeling it's a
great way to start the morning
[Music]
national parks inspire me national parks
are like this pallet cleanser for the
mind and I love to go out and Hike
Yosemite and Glacier and Zion they were
called America's best idea and I agree
with that it gives you a chance to
really reflect on the space between the
notes for a moment you feel so small
your place in the world seems so small
it sets a great perspective how often do
you go not often enough but it's my
summer vacation everybody else goes to
foreign countries or something I always
go to the national park and it's
egalitarian they're for all of us places
like this are just a jewel to go and
sort of Disconnect from the from the
world for a while and really reflect on
what's important how able are you to
disconnect when you actually go out well
in the National porch you're
disconnected because there's no cell
coverage and so you're you're pretty
distant connected there are over 60
national parks out there I would
encourage everyone to go check one of
them out once you go to one you'll want
to go to all of them
you know the team that I work with at
Apple are some of the brightest people
in the world and they push me to think
about things differently you know to
push me to look at something from a
different lens debate me on topics and I
love this I think it's a very necessary
component to stay inspired I mean having
somebody push you to push your thinking
to tell you that you're wrong to tell
you there's another way to look at it
there's another lens that you should
view a issue by these are Jewels these
are things that we should all be happy
for not not sad that somebody's
disagreeing with us you wind up with one
plus one equal three when you're with a
really great team it's amazing what you
can accomplish I really mean the entire
Apple team I can go out in a retail
store in the retail teams inspire me so
whether I'm in a store or I'm working in
the office it's the entire team how do
you keep your team inspired well that's
a good question question
I try to do the same thing with them
that they do with me which is push them
to look at something differently make
sure that I'm recognizing them for their
contributions all the things that that
you would say is sort of a good leader
would do I really try hard to do have
there been times in your life where you
felt you were lacking inspiration oh
there have been times in my life where I
felt aimless before joining Apple I was
in a funk not really knowing what my
purpose in life was and it really took
coming to Apple for all of that to
change there was a voice in the back of
my head that was saying Go West Young
man go west
and I talked to Steve and and loved him
and wanted to work for him and around
him it was the single most important
decision in my life
I love sports sports definitely inspire
me you know that that last minute
touchdown that last basket right at the
buzzer you feel some of the best of
people in sport because people for at
least a few minutes drop their politics
and their other things that divide
people and they're just all into the
game I remember growing up I would
listen to the Auburn Alabama game which
is called the Iron Bowl on the radio
before it was on TV oh this would be
some of the most exciting calls and
games that that I participated in a few
years later I would be going to college
and going to every game and then now
more recently I actually talked to the
team before the gag they won that game
so it was unfortunately
young people really inspire me I think
you need to work with people from all
different ages because people can
Inspire us that are 12 years old and 20
years old and 90 years old and 100 years
old I don't believe in staying to your
your peer group so to speak I look at
the younger generation and I see a group
that are not married to the old dogmas
of my generation they don't accept that
things can't be a certain way because
they were never that way they want to
change the world I is it at Beirut with
Malala and it was the most incredible
Roundtable that we had with a group of
refugees she wants to help a hundred
million girls get an education that are
denied education today because of their
gender and I think she will do it and
we're going to help her I look at people
like that that just won't accept things
as they are I get very excited about it
whether it's environment or human rights
or are just treating people with dignity
and respect I grew up in the 60s and the
early 70s is when during some of my
formative years and I grew up with
Heroes like Dr Martin Luther King and
Bobby Kennedy people that were really
pushing the boundaries on human rights
in just trying to build a more just
world where everyone is treated with
dignity and respect do you think about
the way you present yourself knowing
that young people also look up to you as
the leader and as someone to model
themselves after yes definitely I had
young people reaching out to me back in
the 2010 2011 and so that had read on
the internet that I was gay and it and
they were on the verge of of making
terrible life decisions of suicide and
so forth because they were being pushed
out by their families and friends and
really really wrenching stories and I
decided uh then that it was that the
best thing that I could do was to be
clear about myself it was the uh
Catalyst for me writing the essay that I
did in 2014.
foreign